a solid day at the office and nothing
much to prove is that what you felt
well uh I'd say it's like my more or
less you know one could argue but it's
like fourth game in a row with the same
uh very I would say boring scenario Yeah
so basically it's like uh okay the first
the first day I lost but this game you
know doesn't count second day one then
okay it was
uh no full game against linear but I
managed to Drew and then it's like four
games which uh
I mean basically they could happen like
I don't know in in every tournament like
a very time control but it like was all
quite a boring draws
so like for example today it's like a
theoretical draw uh I can okay I can
understand track here is not like I mean
probably was not anymore you know you
want to challenge I mean you know
in any principled lines so that's quite
understandable you're having like okay
this uh not the Perfect Score but um
yeah also I had feeling like yes for
example yesterday was yeah like Fabiano
uh picked the line which is not very you
know doesn't suit him too well and not
really the line you don't really expect
from him yeah so like are trying to make
a draw in the worst position without a
pawn okay I mean we we both know it's a
draw but um I would expect you know this
line from a report against whom I played
the game yeah but report didn't came but
he's opening date yeah
yeah I don't know what to say so well of
course it's a little frustrating but
still two more games hopefully we know
that you're a fighting player does it
bother you to make these kind of draws
uh I would say uh
I have nothing no no problem you know no
no no problems at all with the you know
with the sequence of draws but the
problem is most likely my perhaps okay
uh one cannot be sure but perhaps my
last tournament in classical before
before the match here because I'm not
seeing like I'm being invited somewhere
like why can't there or something
uh so yeah that's a little bit
unfortunate but uh yeah maybe you know
when you play less you train more yeah
the match is still pretty far away have
you been given any kind of more or less
dates uh no not really so it's uh okay
they say it's April May so probably uh
the second half of April okay perfect
did you know there's a punishment for
people that finish too early
sure yes you have to come here and
analyze it now okay tell us a little bit
about what your thoughts are your
Greenfield player uh it seems like in
this particular position
the engines thing at zero zero do you
think that there's any possibility for
pressure beware of using engine yeah yes
well uh I thought it's always it was
always critical like to play 9v5 instead
of
uh not be free in this position I'd be
fine but you know when you have like
Peter swindler you know
in the commentators uh yeah maybe it's a
little bit you know too much to ask me
like as a group of expert especially
since I'm not playing Greenfield for
quite some time but yeah this is the
line I played for so many times
I think from foreign
things and again before it's just
playable so the surely what benefits
maximum in this position that's like
it's the Greenfield from the both colors
here so yes symmetrical Greenfield and
perhaps he has slightly better
experience here but yeah okay this
Knight 26s looks a little bit misplaced
and if you know if black won't want to
do something quickly about it it would
be just
slowly you know get forced in the worst
because okay you can you say free porn
and a seven Pawn I think like especially
in the symmetrical structure with uh
quite some you know time Advantage I
mean Tempe Advantage for white it's
yeah it could be quite something there
so the position maybe is far from from
being trivial but I would say it's quite
unpleasant for black kids as as what I
see now okay uh white black just play
them with Bishop E6 we have the move
Queen C2 seems to be a novelty it seems
like the only games they got here did go
Knight D2 Quincy 2 seems very logical to
me however
um Queen situ's like you don't trade off
the Queens here right yeah I mean the
question the question has to be if they
play Bishop 5 here do we gobish before
like what's all right well surely I
think it's between like okay Queen D2 is
not
I mean I'm not sure can do to his
Improvement comparing to Queen D1 yes
exactly
decides to trade the Queens yeah so yeah
Bishop before is logical okay sometimes
also Knight E4 would would take you know
about like 94 because 94 I think Queen
be free it's it means no no I mean
immediately if you play 94 immediately
uh ah here okay some some tricks yeah
okay Knight G5 is yeah surely the move
which would be found in a second yeah
Charlotte uh yeah so okay Bishop before
but uh well sometimes you just have to
you know to say goodbye to this uh you
know Catalan Greenfield Bishop yeah but
uh instead of this you're getting all
these like brilliant uh
this is yeah like I mean every every
piece from White is actually fine Ruby
one is coming so this is yeah Rook D1 is
coming queen in the center yeah Bishop's
really nice yeah by the way by the way
it's like it's a big difference a big
difference in how like the Queens are
placed so like Queen only four is
probably like arguably the most dominant
Square for the queen yeah right
uh that was a little bit are you
familiar with this and yeah at least I
played against left and Blitz uh I mean
in his chest come Blitz championships
Championship or something and uh I
really thought this like some some sort
of throwaway prep because it's uh no I
mean I didn't know what to play against
Baron so I decided to play this explain
to our audience what does it mean a
throwaway prep I mean probably the prep
you don't really expect too much of here
so even if it works like like here yeah
clearly uh Fabiano is more or less in
stealing his book uh but she don't
really achieve something yeah so in the
I think in this particular line it's
only only one move which black has to
know is A5 because if not E5 it's I mean
I think black has different tries but
somehow A5 like is very smart position
in real you like white never plays for
the connected best bones yeah yeah
because you immediately yeah and you
exchange it okay you have to be A6 B6
I'm I can I can recall like I was
analyzing this position I was like he's
sort of excited as well like finally we
have something against these D5 versus
Berlin yeah which is uh you know quite
annoying so for example like you get
let's say Italian type structure if like
it's not going for D5 but D5 is more or
less a try to make it draw by force uh
which uh however as far as I know for
for the current situation is not refuted
yes no not yet and okay this was one of
the tries and I played against him uh
the line and I think I think I guess it
may be a slightly better position but
then okay some maybe a blunder it Rook
or a pawn or a bishop so that's a pretty
different drawback of playing some you
know some prep in in Bliss tournament
yeah especially online we don't have
Blitz Games here uh how did the game go
was it exactly this variation all the
way to A5 yeah oh no know I think it was
like King situ for sure maybe maybe if
it can be true there are two most
basically King featuring King V2 so here
if someone has just bass or I don't know
someone lined it a bit surely you would
find this we'll take a look or uh yeah
or maybe maybe searches that like
uh let me let me give you let me give
you a second we got Peter on it and then
we only have one game left
to dabble on the night or guess your
thoughts on this position uh I think
it's used to be quite a line which
probably better again against you know
again Peter himself played this against
the shook I think but yeah yeah we
discussed it and but it was like 2012
2007.
I don't know Queen F3 right yeah okay I
mean okay it's it's very difficult you
know to surprise linear even with some
you know very very odd sequence of most
and okay this idea I think it also was
played like shook I mean the camera
played this against you shook in some
Moscow Grand Prix right
2017 I think a very good memory yes yeah
because I played there and played
miserably yeah of course because I only
think I had the only thing was left for
me is like uh you know witness other
players yeah in action well you're
starting learning yeah but uh yeah
because okay I think I also I was played
against the carousel neither and he
didn't go for this line against me he
plays ambition G5
so well I I don't know clearly so they
finally started you know to think right
well Lanier hasn't he's spent only a
couple minutes but he doesn't Blitz out
I would say it reads a bit you know
reminds me of the line which uh alireza
played against me in Madrid because
objectively the line is good and
computer yeah it proves you know
stamp yeah computers
it's very it's very I mean humanly it's
for in my opinion yeah I mean even here
yeah it's slightly slightly slightly
easier to play as white because Arena
you always have two pieces and you you
have you know your your goal is quite
clear and of course like if we you know
remove the queen suits I mean when we
say the goal is quite clear remember we
have a big audience ah okay uh give a
mate very good very good very good they
say that that's that's the way between
each other a game of chess yeah so here
okay the king is exposed and as for me I
would not I would not be sure that much
about you know castling kingside uh up
on Queen side I would say that probably
you know Queen side to me would be more
logical because then you can come up
with something I don't know H5
G4 but maybe it's like the same problem
because okay Rook B1 and white quickly
yeah you know quickly brings all the
pieces into something like there's 93
Rook B1 so probably the opposition is
all right for black a and mathematically
but uh once again when you're out of
your book okay when your knowledge is
uh uh you can probably continue the
position until maybe the castle or
something can hear okay probably okay
you can make a couple of things like
rookie four Rook f8 I mean okay very
very helpful errors here and the white
Place Ginger two queen D3 yeah okay you
see I can
I I can only play by reading theirs yeah
but yeah okay now it says for example H4
yeah
no but it doesn't matter very smart no
Queen yeah it's very it's very I mean
easy for white so you just with every
next move you create another threat
that's how you basically deal with this
position because of course if like if
Lex gets his time like uh
make sure okay the king is secure like I
don't know uh takes like some key
squares from White Airline and by moving
deep pool and maybe okay creating some
passive Pawn on on the queen side which
is so I mean already in a realistic
scenario then okay then back surely like
has an upper hand but for now it's like
very very concrete position and what
white wants is like yeah all right well
just open up open up things and I found
what happens yeah on the topic of the
Italian I found if it's only one game
you played against Lev you you did
indeed kind of blunder upon at the very
very beginning
uh because uh the game I found did not
even feature Knight E5 D5 there's a game
where young played King C2 instead of
Knight takes C5 there ah yeah probably
probably yeah because yeah maybe I
thought uh but I would say that maybe
should be more transpose yeah Knight C4
Bishop C1 Bishop takes F2 and the game
continued from there while definitely
has compensation here but no I mean this
is this is somehow this is somehow
budget for what I can recall but yeah I
think in case if if you would took a
take on F2 it's just I mean a draw which
is
It's relatively simple
but yeah well yeah thank you for all
that analysis though certainly covered
the games we have left I hope that we
see some great chess coming up in the
next two rounds I hope so thank you
thank you all right guys thank you Jan
for uh taking over our job and